[Music]
on the surface you'd struggle to notice
the difference at London Fashion Week
it's still a battle to see and be seen
but in between the shows this is what
you'll find
hand sanitizer aplenty efforts to stop
the potential spread of kovat 19 the
corona virus for fashion its impact has
been far-reaching affecting the health
of the industry itself in ways that
can't simply be wiped away any industry
that has a Chinese audience has
production in China is being affected by
the coroner virus at the moment
businesses are looking to 3 6 12 months
scenario until we get straight that
first quarter and understand potentially
what the next three months might look
like I think businesses will be cautious
China's influence in fashion has
steadily increased over the last two
decades with Chinese spending reported
to account for one third of the global
luxury market but widening travel
restrictions have forced press
influences and customers to stay away
investors and buyers missing from the
front row there's real concern that
what's happening over in Asia is
massively disrupting to a supply chain
that so many of our designers rely
heavily on designer you Han Wang was
forced to change her show her lucrative
season which met in China wasn't able to
arrive and all the factors had gone the
indefinite closure of factories presents
a real dilemma for the high street to
switch when they manufacture or hold
their nerve high street chain next
source is 20% of its products from China
for Primark roughly half of its clothes
come from 525 Chinese factories as for
the effects on Asian shopping habits
British brand Burberry says it's
temporarily closed 24 stores in mainland
China with its chief executive warning
the outbreak is having a material
negative effect on luxury demand there
is interest in bringing some
manufacturing for high street brands
from multinational
to the UK because there are concerns
about hitting targets for now designer
face masks are a quirky accessory but
long term the fashion industry knows
this isn't a good look Katie Spencer Sky
News